Jon Gosselin went from starring on a
reality show to working in the kitchen
et learned on Wednesday that the John
and Kate Plus eight alum had a job as a
cook at TGI Fridays in Lancaster
Pennsylvania
despite his headline generating gig Jon
exclusively told et he only works
part-time and doesn't see why it's
become a big deal quote why can't I work
at a restaurant I do it because I'm
passionate about cooking no one knew
that about me because TLC never put it
out there my buddy needed help so I said
okay why not I'll saute John says he
left the popular restaurant chain after
a co-worker exposed him but tells us he
may consider going back he also admits
it's hard to find a job because he could
bring unwanted attention quotes
employers won't hire me because I'm a
public figure this isn't the first time
the dad of eight picked up a new line of
work outside of the small screen I'm
busy doing mine I work at night a lot
I'm a DJ so John currently makes a
living spinning on the ones and twos as
DJ Jay G at building 24